[Applause]
we're back with the legendary matthew
mcconaughey
that word really applies matthew and i
was lucky enough to know you gosh when
was boys on the side i'm the worst i'm a
pisces i was 94.
yeah i was 19 exactly 1994.
just a couple of kids um your
beautiful wife was kind enough
with your mom kay to come on the show we
had a really really nice time
they had a wonderful time too yeah um i
knew that would be a good combination
you and them she is she is uh she is
wonderful and then you got to meet is
that the first time you met my mom
before probably down in tucson we worked
together right that's exactly right yeah
totally yeah we met um apparently almost
27 years ago which
is just so crazy matthew in honor of
your new book
green lights we'd like to play something
we're calling red light green light
okay
are you gabe i i'm ready i i can i can
already tell what my biggest challenge
with this game is going to be
okay well let's see what that is yeah
i'm such an optimist i'm going to wonder
if i can actually
really say that's a red light
i have an optimism problem too but you
know what let's see
good problem to have let's let's have it
and turn it up a notch
exactly okay here's how it works we're
gonna name some people places or things
nouns um and situations and we'll give
them a green light
if you're into it or a red light if
you're not and you know what
you're probably not bagging on anyone
you're just saying what you like and
don't like
do all right here we go let's do it all
right
number one everybody's talking about it
and you were in the
original the sex in the city reboot
yes i i was in one of those that's a
green light
and you're so good in that scene in the
office i mean come
on it's the best
i don't really remember what i did i
remember i made some strong choices and
after we did take one
the director producer was like okay
so is is is is that what you're gonna do
press record man that's what i just did
that's who i am that's what i'm doing
i believe there might have been like a
leg up on a table moment also which is
just
so that's a big green light for me
green light okay carbs red light or
green light
carbohydrates yeah i'm big green light
there
um plus if you got a it's a good way to
get everyone to be
fed especially if you don't have much
food you get to con it can
fill up fill a belly up a little bit
especially when you get a little water
behind it to fill it up so yeah i'm full
green light on bread
i personally don't eat a bunch every day
but boy i know
uh we need bread and the world needs
bread okay
bumper stickers red light or green light
big green light you know i love bumper
stickers so much though that i made of
one word bumper and sticker stuck them
together i
bumper stickers it's almost one of the
last bastions
of of innocent free speech isn't it it's
like
you can put on there you can tell who
someone voted for you can tell if they
got kids if they got pets
if they're religious if they're atheist
you can tell so much
about somebody from a doggone bumper
sticker and i always find this really
fun you pull up behind somebody
you check out their bumper stickers so
now you get an image of who that person
is and it's very fun to now pass that
person when the light turns green
and see if the picture of them matches
who you thought they were
and sometimes it's right on the money
sometimes it's completely opposite of
what you thought
i love it growing up in california
bumper stickers
you know big things so i'm glad you feel
that way
okay an inner tube in a six-pack green
light or red light
major green light in um central texas we
would always head down
actually did it on sundays almost each
sunday
after church you go down
to a beautiful spring fed river a
truck where you go rent the tubes you
takes you up river
you get in the water you all have in
there too but you have an extra inner
tube because you have a cooler for that
cold six-pack
and you slowly float the river and it is
called trickle time
and it is good time to spend i think i
might have a new bumper sticker and it
says trickle time
jiggle time green light okay we know you
just adopted a new dog but buzzfeed has
an
article about unusual pets like
tarantulas and chinchillas
my daughter wants a snake right now oh
um oh yeah
red light or green light on unusual pets
i'm the green light of it look i'm my
i've got a child that wants a snake too
um that child's mother has made it very
clear that that ain't happening
um uh we had a chameleon so that would
be
i was green lighting uh strange animals
as pets then so yeah i'm green light
to each a zone yellow light green light
all of the lights um well
matthew you are a light for
all of us so thank you and you're so fun
i mean come
on ladies and gentlemen green lights is
out now it's a new york times bestseller
we're all celebrating it and um matthew
thank you so much i hope to see you soon
and my best
to your gorgeous wife and beautiful
mother
camilla and kay give big hello to them
please i'll do it
i'll give him a hug for me and i look
forward to giving you a hug next have a
seat yes
i can't wait
you